Hello, everyone,
and welcome to this
month's enterprise community meetup,
where we'll discuss another end to
end data science workflow using Posit Team
My name is Ryan Johnson,
and I'm a data science
advisor here at Posit.
And I'm joined by a few
of my colleagues who will be hanging
out in the YouTube chat
during the webinar.
And we'll stick around
afterward to answer any
questions you may have about
the content we'll go over today.
As a reminder,
This is a recurring event on
the last Wednesday of every month,
and the goal is to provide
the data science community with an
overview of Posit Team.
These demos are
open to everyone,
and the attendance over the
past few months has been awesome.
But feel free to share
these webinars with your colleagues, friends,
or anyone else that is looking
to improve their own data
science workflows
with Poist tools.
Now for this month's topic,
we're gonna focus on how to
create a FastAPI in Python,
and then show how this API
can more or less build bridges
between the various steps
of your data science workflow.
Now before we dive into
creating a fast API,
let's quickly
review Posit Team.
Posit Team is a
bundled offering of our three
professional data science
tools. Posit Workbench,
Posit Connect, and
Posit Package Manager.
Now,
taking a look at the diagram
on your screen will start at the
very top with the data analyst.
Who will be writing code and
creating insights
using Posit Workbench.
They can choose to write
code in either R or Python.
And they have a variety
of IDEs to choose from,
including RStudio,
JupyterLabs, Jupyter
Notebooks, and VS code.
For R developers,
they may be creating
content such as shiny applications,
pins, RMarkdown,
or Plumber APIs,
And for Python developers,
they may be creating
content such as Flask or
FastAPIs, streamlit, shiny
or Dash applications, Pins,
or Jupyter notebooks.
Once the content is created,
The developers will need a
way to easily share that content
with the people
that need to see it,
and that's where Posit
Connect comes into play.
Connect not only makes
your content shareable,
but also gives your team
tight control over content access.
Finally, we have
Posit Package Manager,
which does exactly as this
name implies, and that's to host,
organize, and distribute open
source R and Python packages,
not only from the community
but also any internally developed R
or Python packages.
For today's workflow,
we will use VS Code from
within Posit Workbench
to develop a FastAPI in Python.
And to keep things
nice and simple,
we're going to design this
API to do only one thing, and
that's to serve data.
We'll then publish this FastAPI
to Posit Connect and show how
it can serve as a gateway to
your data which can be
accessed by multiple pieces of content
using Python, R, or any
other language or system.
Now many of you may be like
me, and when you started your data
science journey, the idea
of working with APIs,
let alone creating your own API
was so daunting that I honestly
tried to avoid working with
APIs at all cost. Well,
I'm here to tell you that
they're not that scary and can
actually be used to vastly
improve your data science workflows.
Now the acronym API stands
for application programming
interface, and they
essentially allow communication
between applications.
To help explain what APIs are,
I like to think of the commonly
used restaurant analogy you
see on your screen here.
Here we have three customers
that have entered a restaurant,
and would like to order some
food that the chef in the
kitchen will prepare.
To request food,
the customers need some way to
communicate their order to the kitchen,
and rarely if ever the customer
will interact directly with the chef.
So that's where the waiter
or waitress comes into play.
They take the order
from the customer,
and can communicate
that order to the chef.
The chef prepares the food,
which is then delivered
back to the customer.
So in this analogy,
the waiter or waitress
allows for communication between the
customers and the chef,
essentially they are the API.
For data scientists,
APIs can be an essential
workflow building block that
gives other users or
applications or systems,
the ability to interact
with the functions you've designed,
the models you've trained,
or the data you've curated.
You also don't need to
be a software engineer or computer
scientist to create an API,
and there are numerous
frameworks in both r and Python
for creating APIs,
including plumber and Flask.
Now for today's workflow, we're
gonna focus on just a FastAPI,
which is one of the most
popular frameworks for creating
APIs using Python given
its simplicity and performance.
Now as I previously
mentioned, the FastAPI
we are gonna build today
and publish to Posit Connect will
essentially serve as
a gateway to our data.
Which can be accessed
by a variety of content.
But like, why would you
want to do this? Well,
there are a few reasons.
The first reason is that
it simplifies your code.
You no longer need to attach
and read in and transform the
data into each individual piece
of content. So this helps also
prevent data duplication
and also standardize data
access across content.
Secondly, by putting data behind
an API, it makes it
easily accessible to
different content types.
For example,
you can have a Jupyter Notebook
built using Python and a Shiny
application built using R access the
same data via the same API.
Later on in this
demo, we'll demonstrate this capability.
Lastly, by publishing the
FastAPI to Posit Connect,
you can control access
to your data by adding an
authentication
layer to your APIs.
And this is a great option
if your team is working with
sensitive data.
Now we are very close
to building our FastAPI,
but I just want to spend
one minute and explain the data
we're going to have
behind this API.
This data is
completely made up,
and I wanted to make it
as simple as possible given our
limited time today. Now this
data, it's also relatively small.
It's only about five hundred
rows and has only two columns.
So the first column is a
random letter in the English alphabet,
and the second column is
a random number from one to
twenty, and that's
pretty much it.
As we go through today's demo,
I want you to think about
where your data lives today. In this
workflow, our data is gonna
live as a local CSV file,
but maybe your data lives in
a database or a shared network
drive or maybe as a
pin on Posit Connect.
By using an API to access
the data, no matter where it lives,
we can standardize how the
data is accessed across your various
pieces of content, and
your entire data science team.
Okay. So let's
build our FastAPI.
On this slide, is all of
the code needed to create a
simple data gateway FastAPI.
And as you can see, it's less
than twenty lines of code.
In the first three lines
of code, we will import the
libraries, modules, and
functions needed for this
workflow, including
FastAPI itself,
the typing module for hinting
at content types, and finally
the Pandas library for reading
in and manipulating our data.
We next create the FastAPI
instance using the
FastAPI function,
which we'll call
app in this example.
Now the first step of our API
is to read in the data as a
dataframe using the read_csv
function from pandas.
We'll then store our dataframe
as a variable called large_df.
Next, we define
our API endpoint.
Now an endpoint takes in the
API request, which is usually a URL,
processes it and
sends back a response.
For our FastAPI,
we are using a Git method
for our endpoint, which is
routinely used to read data.
The forward slash followed by
the word data tells the FastAPI
that anything following the
forward slash data in the
request URL are
parameters to the API,
which can be fed
into the function directly below.
And finally, we have
the function itself.
This is where all of the
logic of your FastAPI lives.
In our FastAPI
we are defining a
single function called
get_filtered_data,
and it takes a single
argument called letters.
Letter are captured as a list
of strings when the API is queried.
It's also an optional query
item and defaults to none if
no letters are provided.
So we next use the list
of letters to filter our data.
And if I simply read this
code left to right top to
bottom, we start by asking
if the query contained any
letters. If yes, the data is
then filtered for
those specific letters,
and returned by the function.
If no letters are provided,
it simply returns the entire
dataset itself.
So now that we have
all the code needed,
I'm going to copy
it to my clipboard
and then navigate over
to Posit Workbench.
So here's the home page
for Posit Workbench,
and you can see that I
currently have three separate
sessions running.
I have a VS Code
session, RStudio session,
and a Jupyter notebook session.
So I'm gonna first navigate
into this VS Code session,
which I currently have
open in another tab,
so I'll click on that.
And once here,
you'll notice that I'm
currently within a directory I
called FastAPI_Demo. And I
previously created a virtual
environment in this directory,
which is called .venv,
and I'm first gonna activate
this virtual environment,
So to do that, I'm going
to open up a new terminal.
Click on these three lines
in the top left corner,
select terminal
and new terminal.
And once we have our
prompt, I want to source
the activate script within
that environment. So
source .venv/bin/activate and hit
enter. Oops. Spelled source
wrong. Let's go
ahead and fix that.
And there we go. I
now have my virtual environment activated,
and this is typically
best practice,
And it's a great idea just to
ensure that the work we do here
is isolated from any other
project currently on Posit Workbench.
So let's go ahead and create
a new Python file by clicking the
new file button, which
you can find, again,
clicking on these three
lines, file, new file.
Now I'm gonna
call this main.py,
hit enter.
We're gonna place it in
our current working directory, hit okay.
You can see it show up
here on the file explorer,
and now we have our file
which is completely empty,
and let's go ahead and
paste in that FastAPI.
So now that it's been created,
let's go ahead and show you
how to publish this FastAPI
to Posit Connect using the
RSConnect Python package, which
I previously installed
into this environment.
So the RSConnect
Python package,
it provides a command
line interface,
so you can use it within
the terminal down here for
deploying content
to POS Connect.
So I'm gonna type out
the command here in the command
line, and I'm gonna explain
each step along the way.
So we first need to I'll
make my screen a little bit bigger
here. We first need to tell rsconnect
to deploy
a FastAPI.
Next, we need to indicate
which Posit Connect instance we will
be deploying to.
Now I previously saved this
connect instance into my
environment, and I gave it the
name pct_prod. So all we need
to do is give it the
name - n pct_prod.
And then finally, we just need
to provide the name and location
of the FastAPI.
So this main file, it
lives in my current working directory,
which we can indicate
with a period,
and then we just have to
provide the name of the file.
Hit enter, and that's
pretty much it.
So this is gonna kick off
the publishing process,
So the RSConnect
Python package,
it's essentially taking a
snapshot of my environment,
including what packages
are in my environment,
package versions, what Python version am
I using, it sends that information
from Posit Workbench
to Posit Connect,
and then deploys this FastAPI.
And so we'll just give this
a few more seconds to publish.
And there we go. It's all done,
and we get these
two links down here,
and so I'm gonna go ahead
and click on the dashboard content,
and that will navigate
us directly to Posit Connect.
Now, once it's deployed, we
can now interact with this FastAPI
on Connect using this swagger interface
that you see on your screen.
Our API, it only has one
get endpoint, and we can try
querying it using various
letters in the alphabet.
And seeing the
resulting API response.
So let's try querying this
fast API to extract all of the
"A" rows in the dataset.
So I'll select get right
here, and we'll try it out.
And here we can add letters,
so I'll add an "A" here,
and then we can hit execute. And
once we hit execute,
the swagger interface,
it'll show you the curl command
that was run to ping the API,
the request URL,
which is right here,
and then if we scroll down,
we can see the response
which is in this JSON format,
where each row of the data
is a chunk of this JSON file.
Let's try a few different
combinations just to make sure
that the API is
behaving correctly.
So let me come back
up here to the top,
and we'll add an additional
string item. So maybe we'll do
let's try "T", and we'll
also try "M" Hit execute,
and we can see the curl
response, the request URL,
and here we can see the
response versus just Ts and Ms.
Now, a major benefit of this
API hosted on Posit Connect is
that you can manage who has access
to it, which is shown right over here.
If I select any of
the options that require authentication
including this bottom option for
specific users or groups or
the middle option all
users login required,
then users of the API
would essentially need to provide an
API key in order to leverage
this API. And that API key,
you can actually login to
connect, click on your name,
and generate those
keys right over here.
So now that we have the
FastAPI hosted on Connect, let's use it
as a gateway for multiple pieces
of content using both R and Python.
And let's actually start with
Python in a Jupyter Notebook.
So let's come back to Posit
Workbench, so we have our three
sessions currently running,
and I'm gonna open
up this Jupyter notebook session,
which I have open in
a separate tab here,
and here's the Jupyter
notebook that I created.
So in this notebook, in this
first code chunk here, we have
few packages and libraries
we need for this analysis,
specifically this request
library which is going to be
important for pinging our API.
So let's run this code chunk.
In the next code
chunk right down here,
we're gonna use that
request library.
To submit a get query to
our API. So you can see that
request URL right here, and
we're gonna feed in two parameters,
so we're essentially gonna
extract data where the letters
column is equal to f, g, or
r. So let's go ahead and run this.
And we're gonna take
that JSON response,
and we're gonna convert it
into a dataframe using the Pandas
package. So we'll
run this code chunk,
and you can see
the output of that
the query for the API.
And then finally,
we're gonna take this resulting
data frame that we received
from the API, and we're gonna
create a plot to visualize it.
And we do that
using the swarmplot
from the seaborne
package in Python.
So also it's just worth noting,
that I didn't have to
manually upload and filter the data.
You know, the fast
API does this for us.
So that's how to query the
API from within a Python Jupyter notebook.
Let's actually switch gears to the
R language and call the API
from within a
shiny application.
So I'm gonna come back
here to Posit Workbench,
and we'll open up
this RStudio session,
which again I have open in
another tab. Which is right here.
Now we won't go
in-depth regarding the underlying
shiny code here, but I do want
to show how the fast API is
being queried from within
this shiny application.
So here in the top left
corner, this is the shiny application.
It's nothing but R code,
which is used to create
interactive web applications.
So we're gonna use a
shiny package for this,
but also note that we're
using this jsonLite and httr
package to interact
with our API.
So I'm gonna scroll down here
to the server function and just
highlight a few lines of code
which is gonna be important for
pinging our API.
So this first bit
of code right here,
this is where we actually ping
that API, so we feed it that
API URL, which I
saved as a variable,
and we can provide some
query parameters to that API.
We then take that response,
alright, we gather it here,
and then we convert that
JSON responds into a data frame,
which will eventually be
converted over to a Tibble.
We save that as a response
data which gets fed into a ggplot.
Let's go ahead and run
this shiny application so you can
see how it works.
So the first thing you'll
see here is this input box,
and this is where we can choose
as many letters as we want.
So I'll select a few
letters. We'll do C, J, M,
let's do P as well. And once
we have the letters selected,
we can then query the API
by clicking on this box.
And then once we do that,
you can see it returns a
plot that's very similar to the plot
we saw on a Jupyter Notebook,
where they have letters
along the X axis,
and the corresponding
numbers along the Y axis.
So that's pretty much it.
So hopefully this was a good
way to show how you can ping
the same API
and access the same
dataset from different content types
written in two
separate languages.
So now that you know a
bit more about how APIs, specifically
FastAPIs work,
we hope that you can
take this knowledge and incorporate it
into your own data
science workflows.
So thanks again everybody
for joining today,
and feel free to stick around
if you have any questions about
what we talked about
today. Otherwise,
have a great rest of your day,
and we hope to see
you again next month.
Thanks so much, Ryan.
As Ryan mentioned,
we're gonna stick around for some Q
&amp; A for another fifteen minutes or so.
YouTube should automatically push you
over to that but I
know that wasn't as
straightforward last month,
so I've also included the link
in the details below in the
YouTube description,
and we'll also copy that over to
the chat right now too. As a reminder,
there's also a Slido open
for anonymous questions,
and so that's at
pos.it/demo-questions.
And we'll keep that open for
the rest of the week as well,
and we can add the answers
there in Slido too.
But thank you again for joining
us today and then we'll see you
over there in the Q &amp; A.